δναφιλάξουμε και πρέπει να εξηγήσουμε του κόσμου να καταλάβει γιατί είμαστε νεδοπου είμαστε σήμεραοι κύπρος
έχει τα φράγματα της πέραν των εκατόν οι κύπρος έχει πέντε μονάδες αφαλάτωσης αυτές οι
υποδομίες μας καλύπτουν τις ανάγκες μας σε νερό για να πίνουμε στο ευδομήντα της εκατό
εμείς αυτοή τις στιγμή είναι περίοδο κρίσις καλούμαστε να καλύψουμε το κριάντα τις εκατόν από
τα φράγματα τα οποία έχουν ελάχει στων νερό μέσα και το ποιο σημαντικό όμος που
κάνουμε είναι να δίνουμε μόνοι μιλήσει σε αυτό το πρόβλημο το οποίο χρονίι οι μόνι
μιλήση δίνεται μέσα από την ηλοποίση του προγράμμα στων κοσιοκτότερασα με τις δύ επιπλόο να
φαλαδώσεις και τις τεσσρης κοινητές μονάτες αλλά υπάρχει και μια ακόμα πολιτικοή απόφαση οι οποί
είναι πολύ σημαντικί το ότι ι αφαλατώσεις δεν θα χρησιμοποιούνται ευκαιριακά δεν θα χρησιμοποιούνται όποτε
δεν βρέχει θα χρησιμοποιούνται συνεχώς διότι με χρη σήμερα τις χρησιμοποιούσαμε όποτε δεν εβρεε με
αποτέλεσμα να σκούμε μποίησης στα φράγματα εμείς θέλουμε τα φράγματα μας να είναι εκεί να
υπάρχουν ασφαλί αποθέματα για να δίνουμε στους γεοργούς μας το νερό που χρειάζουνται για να
παράγουν έτσι και να μπορεί και ο κόσμους να συνεχίσει να καλύποεμοαδ κταλάο ελουλεο σήμερα
δουλεύουν ι τέσσερης υπέπείναι ναι υποκατασκερί η καέκλα τηπογογγια κααυτή όλες οι καρέκλες τον υπουργώναν
είναι καφτές και ήταν ημεράετρ δυσκολί απάντιμετοπισες όλα αυτό το διάστημα πουίσεξεκοινώντας με την ανάλειψη
τον καθεκόντομου υπρώτη και οσημαντική έτσι τις κολύ εδα φυσικά υπυρκαγές διότι δεν υπήρχε καμία
συμβασι ενεργεί έπρεπε να δημιουργήσω τι συμβάσεις από τομιδε για αυτόν και επειδή υγήρχαν είνα
νομισμένες διαδικασίες για να μπορέσνανταέλθο